I'm high tea
well let's get to talking all about your
amazing beautiful of this very cool yes
this character is there so many
dimensions
it was the character that's actually
going crazy and seeing the
happy on the SWAT team and then there's
the one the kind of Couture one and this
she's in this highly fabulous padded
room if you will and full-on culture
head-to-toe and call it the straitjacket
chic we were calling it through this
whole video each detail in the brain of
a metallic while of deliberate terror
bring about first yeah
was it fun shooting this that was yeah I
loved going into the different
characters because they're quite crazy
yeah in that video for the video oh it
is so cool bad red hair twice in this
yeah album yeah once it's a morning runs
here she is the me and my girls in the
club she basically because the whole
thing was this kind of retro fabulous
in vehicle is buying this Italian folk
version of my trophy set the milk bar
over it where no she works yes the diner
and she supposedly owns it as well own
in the club buying the bar what was it
like to shoot at holding a single makeup
done by is my French weight done by Andy
look yes that is a way that's shocking
um yeah but we had these all custom-made
by a latex designer Venus I do a lot of
latex and yeah this video thank you that
was like a sermon about the cherry hair
shirt alert for those for Monday's no no
everything was a detail a little back
yeah sort of like some [ __ ] delicious
yeah yes absolutely [ __ ] coat hook
thank you to the gym yeah up in the gym
working on my fitness yes I have the
Domino nails here done by Ann and Ken in
LA
yeah you know in half my hair brunette
blonde white girl with beef burger
delicious I love this is so much fun
and I know it's of course I had my
piercings here still my eyebrow there's
Union and all of my gosh there are team
here takes up my ear yes I'm in each ear
so the next one is I love oh yes that
was done by brony chapeau thank you yes
good yes I love that because I go you
always have my complete I love that 300
I live that was with a black liquid
liner but with an inner liner as well
the hair was done by Andy Andy lecompt
kind of an ode to Madonna's when she
started wearing that see look look oh my
a toy top yeah I did her in air so it's
very much yes I'm Paul Gautier and then
I you know I'm sorry the last this is
the last collection that we did for
ready-to-wear yeah so it's kind of again
with a job yeah yeah so routine exactly
so now that's going on Kluber run an
arrest
yes I love this this was um I was gonna
sleep again yes it was I was completely
paying homage I was trying to do the
hair flip from that Rita Hayworth
Gilda and so but this is right when I
flipped my head up yeah yeah and so we
did that a few times to make sure that
we got that code in right yeah yeah
correctly so that wasn't hungry
yes gosh we started out shaky yeah yeah
we got that I love this black and white
this is a total double Dutchess look
with the dark roots the dark and the
light which is one of the themes on the
album so that's just it's about my do
you wanna be on folk who did the art
direction on the album was he's like cut
the hair it's time to cut the hair so we
did this whole trailer of me cutting my
hair and kind of releasing any of the
any negative energy or or you know fresh
start my heart starts and it was my
pregnancy here I let it grow since I had
gotten pretty with that muscle so it was
I just hadn't had any reason to cut it
down but so he and then advocates like
time to chop it so he got that on camera
and then and the conference his idea to
do the dark underneath yeah which is
kind of a blondie tribute at Debbie
Harry okay make sure you and so we did
that and and the dark and the light it's
like the dark side of me and the lighter
side of me yeah cuz I go kind of dark
and some of them
but he also encouraged me to to really
refine my my boyish side which I was
very much embracing in like 2003 to the
anaphors very tomboy which and they had
to beg me to wear heels yeah and so so
he in this way came in Korea not to tell
the unstyled a lot of my stuff got me
into menswear and kind of doing a grown
woman boss version of that tomboy so
it's like you know grow grow so yeah
yeah so it was like finding my you know
harder side yeah many swear which I
really embraced it was it's been so much
fun and now I'm obsessed hey ray litter
we are having high tea I was probably
high here lies anyways um via the guard
which i yeah i'm just giving a mugging
i'm straight and it's called this
straight buggin
yeah I'm just I was in a dance move and
I've got the lower pigtails cuz I was
kind of doing a riff on the my family's
tartan so and then I did all throughout
this I did like that kind of it was like
a play on with the plaid on the school
girl oh it sounds good well mixed with
just kind of hood Street yeah several
themes
he always onc a meaning behind
everything well well since it's under
bridge should have another superpower
for
just return Akane Downton Abbey